ok dans exactement deux minutes 17
secondes les lémuriens vont couper les
cheveux c'est leur nom j'y vais non
c'est bon non je descend en rappel je
chantais pas voir toi tu prends monde et
on sait là quant au sexe et c'est moi
qui descend c'est moi qui choque le plus
loin et à patte d'oie martin maintenant
non je bosse dans un chef doit penser à
tout mais pourquoi ces douze chefs 1
pourquoi c'est pas moi ce que je suis le
contrôleur de théâtre qui tu es le grand
maître de la fin du mois j'ai voté moi
parce que je suis chef doit bien jouer
mais je pousse non
c'est moi je devrais prendre les
commandes main je suis médecin
maintenant ne raconterai pas touche est
fou mais laissez-moi à la quête
c'est dangereux